- Um, Tzuyu, Tsuyu?
- [Translator] Suyu or chewy.
- Chewy? Okay.
Wait, wait, what?
- [Translator] Suyu is good.
(audience laughing)
- No, no, Tsuyu?
How would, how do you say it?
- [Translator] In Korean, it's chewy.
- Chewy?
How do you want me to say it?
(Translator speaking in Korean)
- [Kelly] Chewy?
- Tzuyu.
Oh, how you say it's adorable.
(everyone laughing)
Okay. So, Tzuyu, I think I said it right.
- [Translator] Yeah.
- I'm trying.
So you're performing your single
"MOONLIGHT SUNRISE" today,
so what's the song about?
(Translator speaking in Korean)
(Tzuyu speaking in Korean)
- [Translator] So "MOONLIGHT
SUNRISE" is a song
about wanting to know
the other person's heart,
and they use the metaphor
of moonlight and sunrise
to parallel that fluttering heart feeling
when you're in love.
- [Kelly] Oh, I like that.
(audience cheers)